[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend die
Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz hat schon
manch stürmische Zeiten erlebt und
vergessen etwa wie Wladimir Putin dort
2007 eine aggressive Brandrede hielt die
eine Vorausschau gab auf das was kommen
sollte im letzten Jahr fand die
Konferenz kurz vor dem russischen
Angriff auf die Ukraine statt der
russische Außenminister war damals noch
eingeladen erschien aber nicht vier Tage
später fielen die ersten Raketen auf
Kiew die Amerikaner hatten davor gewarnt
nicht jeder hatte ihn glauben wollen nun
versammeln sich also wieder Staats- und
Regierungschefs Militärs und Experten in
München und bei dieser Konferenz hat
diese diese Konferenz hat hinter den
Kulissen auch etwas von einer
Waffenbörse wer kann was liefern
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius um
schwirrt die Gnade des neuen die
verfehlte Russlandpolitik der letzten
Jahre hat er nicht zu verantworten
allein das macht ihn begehrt vielen Dank
dass Sie da sind sie machen das wenn ich
das sagen darf als pensionierter war die
machen das super aber der Chef der
Sicherheitskonferenz Christoph Heusgen
war dagegen der Kopf von Merkels
Russland Politik die nun in Trümmern
liegt er verkörpert den politischen
Irrtum und den Versuch eines Neuanfangs
stellvertretend für viele im Saal
Heusgen hat den einstigen Partner Putin
nicht eingeladen
Putin hat ein Verbrechen gegen die
Zivilisation begangen
das nicht geglaubte Kriegsbilder in
Europa bestimmt den Auftakt der
Sicherheitskonferenz
ihm dem ukrainischen Präsidenten
selenski hatten sie auch nicht geglaubt
als er letztes Jahr auf der Konferenz
vor der Invasion der Russen warnte er
erwähnt das kurzen seiner Rede um seine
Mahnung und Hoffnungen mehr Gewicht zu
geben
selenski sieht eine moralische Pflicht
sein Land als Teil des Westens zu sehen
es gibt keine Alternative zu einem Sieg
der Ukraine es gibt keine Alternative zu
einer Mitgliedschaft der Ukraine in der
EU und in der NATO
unten sitzt Bundeskanzler Scholz der
hört die Wünsche und weiß in der Welt
der Realpolitik dauert es länger sowie
auch die Waffenlieferungen selensky
mahnt die Zeit dränge die russische
Offensive laufe
das ist der Grund warum wir schneller
bei der Hilfe werden müssen wir müssen
schneller die Waffen liefern
Olaf Scholz hat sein eigenes
Entscheidungs Tempo aber diesmal hindert
ihn an einem forschenauftritt die
Technik das Pult muss neu justiert
werden nicht nur da geht es um die
richtige Abstimmung Scholz Zeiten Wände
Politik ein Balanceakt das Ziel
Waffenhilfe für die Ukraine ohne direkte
Eskalation mit Russland
die Balance zwischen bestmöglicher
Unterstützung der Ukraine und der
Vermeidung einer ungewollten Eskalation
werden wir auch weiterhin halten
Scholz trifft die Vize US-Präsidentin
America ist der Garant für Europas
Schutz deshalb macht Scholz nichts ohne
die USA er hat eine panzerkoalition
geschmiedet aber die wackelt jetzt dazu
gehört das alle die solche kampfanze
liefern können dies nun auch wirklich
tun
neben dem Saal der Sicherheitskonferenz
haben sie eine Ausstellung zum Krieg in
der Ukraine im Saal haben die mächtigen
sich gegenseitig versprochen nicht
aufzuhören die Ukraine zu unterstützen
ein Jahr Leid und Tod und ein Ende ist
nicht in Sicht
[Musik]
und das Münchner
Bundesverteidigungsminister zugeschaltet
guten Abend Herr Pistorius
heute beobachtete den Verlauf dieser
Konferenz dann viel an wieder auf wie
komisch sich die Verhältnisse geändert
haben dass nun plötzlich die deutsche
Seite um Panzerlieferungen wirkt
ja das ist so das ist gehört zu den
erstaunlichsten Erfahrungen die ich
gleich zu Beginn meiner Amtszeit machen
durfte aber ja wir haben eine
ordentliche Zahl von Leoparden beisammen
und ich hoffe es kommen noch mehr dazu
sie haben heute morgen gesagt das
wichtigste ist jetzt erstmal mit dem
Polen damit der Rüstungsindustrie zu
sprechen denn es geht ja nicht nur um
die Panzer sondern auch um Ersatzteile
und Munition etc waren die Gespräche die
sie da geführt haben jetzt erfolgreich
ja die waren erfolgreich mein mein
Anspruch war die Rüstungsindustrie
Deutschlands die hier verantwortlich ist
und die Rüstungsindustrie Polens
zusammenzubringen um im Anwesenheit von
Vertretern des polnischen
Verteidigungsministeriums mein Kollege
konnte leider nicht ähm darüber zu
sprechen wie kann jetzt gewährleistet
werden das vor Ort das Material ankommt
was gebraucht wird um die Panzer die in
die Ukraine gehen so weit erforderlichen
Stand zu setzen aber vor allen Dingen
und viel wichtiger Nachschub von
Ersatzteilen und Munitionen über die
nächste Zeit sicher zu stellen und auch
zu klären wie die Logistik aussehen muss
und kann und wo sie untergebracht werden
kann zu entstandsetzung von Panzern die
vom aus dem Kriegsgebiet zurückgeführt
werden müssen
absurde Sachen also dass sie Slowaken
dann die Reparatur von Panzerhaubitzen
und ähnlichem blockieren weil sie
erstmal Zölle kassieren wollen man
wundert sich schon manchmal ein bisschen
über dieses europäische miteinander
ja das stimmt zumal auf polnischer Seite
wo wir auch ein instandsetzungshub haben
diese Probleme nicht existieren aber wir
sind in guten Gesprächen mit der
Slowakei und und hoffen dass wir da
jetzt bald zu einem guten Ende kommen
denn in der Tat ist es ärgerlich wenn
dann wertvolles Gerät was dringend
gebraucht für dem Kriegsgebiet zur
Reparatur nicht einfach über die
Ukrainisch slowakische Grenze gebracht
werden kann sondern nach Deutschland
zurück transportiert werden muss das
sind dann mehrere Tage die dort verloren
gehen die Rüstungsindustrie wartet aber
auch Stichwort es geht Zeit verloren
immer noch auf konkrete Aufträge aus
Berlin für das für neue große Panzer und
anderes Gerät das gebaut werden soll
den Eindruck kann ich nicht teilen ich
habe erst heute wieder mit den
Verantwortlichen der beiden großen
Unternehmen gesprochen beide sind auf
dem Weg die vorbereitenden Beschaffung
bereits zu veranlassen beide wissen dass
es Verträge geben wird noch vor der
Sommerpause und sie haben begonnen damit
gewissermaßen jetzt schon um keine Zeit
zu verschwenden in die Vorbereitung zu
gehen also dieses Problem scheint kein
aktuelles zu sein aber warum sagen denn
die dann die Vertreter der
Rüstungsindustrie wir brauchen auch um
um Waffen zu bauen auch Genehmigungen
konkrete wir können nicht einfach wie
bei so einem Auto mal drauflos bauen und
gucken ob sonst am Ende jemand abkauft
naja das ist auch alles geregelt sie
können das machen das gilt es gibt
bestimmte Begrenzungen für bestimmte
Sachen aber es gibt zusagen und es gibt
Absprachen und ich glaube es ist gut und
das habe ich ja begonnen schon vier Tage
nach Amtsantritt regelmäßig Gespräche zu
führen mit der Rüstungsindustrie um hier
eben auch die Vertrauensbasis zu
schaffen denn das Interesse der
Industrie Verlässlichkeit und
Planungssicherheit zu bekommen kann ich
sehr gut nachvollziehen genauso wie die
Industrie gut nachvollziehen kann welche
Interessen wir als Auftraggeber haben
und das zusammenzuführen da sind wir auf
einem sehr sehr guten Weg guten Tag
diese Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz fast
genau ein Jahr nach dem Beginn der
Angriffe auf auf die Ukraine damals
gegen die Konferenz kurz vorher zu Ende
das wird natürlich auch die Frage auf
wie lange wird dieser Krieg noch dauern
ja das ist eine gute Frage die glaube
ich alle beschäftigt und da wohl am
meisten die Menschen in der Ukraine die
haben meistens darunter leiden jeden Tag
sterben Menschen in diesem Land weil
Putin diesen Aggressionskrieg gegen die
Ukraine begonnen hat und ja ich würde
auch gerne wissen wann er zu Ende geht
aber im Augenblick ist zeichnet sich das
ja ehrlicherweise nicht ab und deswegen
wird es jetzt darum gehen und das war
das Signal auch heute und wird es auch
morgen sein hier von der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz dass wir weiter
ganz fest an der Seite der Ukraine
stehen müssen denn es ist eben wirklich
nicht nur ein Krieg ein Abwehr Krieg der
Ukraine gegen Russland sondern es ist
ein Krieg der freien Welt die sich hier
verteidigen muss gegen die Aggression
Putins und darum geht es und das müssen
wir immer wieder deutlich machen es gibt
ein neues Politbarometer also Umfragen
auch mit der Frage nach der
Unterstützung für die Ukraine da zeigt
sich das doch ein große Mehrheit der
Bevölkerung der deutschen Bevölkerung
weiterhin bereit ist die Ukraine zu
unterstützen aber gleichzeitig gibt es
sehr sehr große Zweifel daran dass die
Ukraine gegen die Russen gewinnen können
glauben denn eigentlich die NATO möchte
die Unterstützer ten an diesen Sieg
ja ich glaube das ist der der Eindruck
den man mitnehmen kann ich sehe das ich
sehe das jedenfalls so und ja ich
verstehe das ist Menschen gibt in
Deutschland und in Europa die daran
nicht glauben ich meine das war der
Glaube den viele hatten zu Beginn des
Krieges dass das nicht lange gut gehen
kann und die Ukraine erteilen uns allen
gerade aber vor allen Dingen den Russen
eine Lektion in Tapferkeit und Mut und
Durchhaltevermögen und davor kann man
nur den Hut ziehen und ja es ist richtig
es geht weiter um die Unterstützung der
Ukraine in diesem Konflikt und das ein
Teil der Menschen in Deutschland sich
Sorgen darüber macht was das bedeuten
kann verstehe ich nur zu gut es ist kein
Spiel das hier stattfindet das ist ein
bitterer Ernst es ist Krieg und dann
muss jeder Entscheidung gut abgewogen
werden aber was ja doch als Elefant im
Raum steht auch bei dieser Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz ist die Frage wie
definiert man denn eigentlich was heißt
das die Ukraine darf nicht verlieren
oder was heißt das Putin darf nicht
gewinnen gleichzeitig wenn man eine
Balance halten man will offenbar auch
nicht zu viel eskalieren also gibt es
auch ja auch dosiert Waffen wird darüber
dann auch gesprochen werden was was
heißt denn eigentlich das Ende dieses
Krieges was können wir uns überhaupt
noch vorstellen
ja das ist eine das ist die schwierigste
Frage überhaupt aber keine die wir hier
in München miteinander wirklich
besprechen können das ist eine Frage die
vor allen Dingen die Ukraine auch
definieren muss denn sie ist das Land
was hier angegriffen wird in seiner
territorialen Integrität und
Souveränität und das musste darum gehen
eine eine Ausgangsposition zu schaffen
die ist der Ukraine erlaubt aus einer
Position der Stärke und das
militärischen Erfolgs heraus
Friedensverhandlungen zu führen wenn es
denn überhaupt dazu kommen kann Putin
macht ja keinerlei Anstalten hier sich
irgendwie zu bewegen er ist derjenige
der seine Armeen sofort zurückziehen
könnte und damit den Weg frei machen
könnte das jetzt nicht aus da Historie
ist danke für das Gespräch
sehr gerne
das Interview haben wir am frühen Abend
aufgezeichnet mehr Hintergründe zur
Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz und dem
Krieg in der Ukraine finden Sie
natürlich auch online auf ZDF heute
wie sehr die ukrainische Armee auf
Nachschub angewiesen ist zeigt sich bei
bachmund wie von Stadt in der Region so
Netz in Osten der Ukraine tobt ja seit
Monaten ein erbitterter Stellungskrieg
für die Ukraine ist die wichtig um ihre
Verteidigungslinien aufrecht zu erhalten
zugleich hoffen sie dass die hohen
Verluste die russische Seite Schwächen
man kann sich aber kaum vorstellen dass
in dieser Gegend immer noch Zivilisten
aushachen Armee und Polizei versuchen
sie zur Flucht zu überreden nicht immer
mit Erfolg wie Arnd Ginzel beobachtet
der freie Journalist ist derzeit in der
Region bachmut unterwegs was er dort
gefilmt hat fast Christian von
Rechenberg zusammen
der Unimog hat Leben gerettet erzählen
Russland und seine Leute gute Technik
aus Deutschland 55 Sanitätswagen hätten
sie bekommen mit diesem waren sie in der
Hölle in bachmut nicht weit weg jeden
Tag schwer verletzte der Krieg und ihnen
keine Pause selbst diese war nicht
geplant die Reifen wurden von
Granatsplittern getroffen alles hier
Granatsplitter neue Reifen gibt's im
Postlager heißen Kaffee und Lebensmittel
nebenan etwas Zeit zum Reden bevor es
zurückgeht in die Hölle die Hölle hat
viele Namen für die Polizistin Valeska
gianikova ist es toske und kein Tag
vergeht ohne Bomben Terror und nur noch
immer Menschenleben
die müssen wir rausholen an sichere Orte
bringen vor allem die Familien mit
Kindern die sollen hier nicht sein
sondern an der Front
doch die meisten wollen nicht weg
Polizei hin oder her nicht mal die
Kinder dürfen sie und der Kollege in
Sicherheit bringen
bin will ich dieses Haus nicht verlassen
weil wenn ich es verlasse bleibt nach 30
Minuten von dem Haus nichts mehr übrig
Angst trotz Verzweiflung die Frau zeigt
dem Reporter den Keller ein sicherer Ort
sei das kein Grund also wegzugehen
Valeska cernikova wird nicht aufgeben
morgen kommt sie wieder neuer Versuch
auch bei dieser Familie die bleiben will
allen Gefahren zum Trotz das Team redet
mit Engels Zungen vergeben
wie das denn
wie können die Kinder irgendwohin
evakuiert werden ich gehe doch auch
nicht weg
es scheint als hätten sie sich
aufgegeben die Familie wirkt verstört
traumatisiert vor allem die Kinder
meine Tiere sind doch alle hier die kann
ich doch nicht einfach im Stich lassen
meine Täubchen mein Hund die brauchen
mich doch
Geborgenheit Sicherheit dieses Kind fand
beides bei der Großmutter die Eltern
verschollen verschwunden das Kind blieb
zurück doch die alte Frau hatte nicht
genug Kraft zu fliehen jetzt will sie es
versuchen gleich morgen weggehen
zurück in konstantinivka trifft das Team
auf andre bekommt wohl direkt vom
Häuserkampf Mann gegen Mann nun soll er
sich etwas erholen bloß wie sein
Gesichtsausdruck spricht Bände mit 24
Kameraden sagt er kam er nach bachmut
nur acht sind zurückgekehrt ja acht wir
hatten verletzte Tote
und so bleibt er zurück bleiben die
ukrainischen Soldaten zurück an diesem
letzten Treffpunkt vor der Hölle auf der
Suche nach Material Kaffee und
Gesprächen allein gelassen mit den
Bildern in ihren Köpfen und der Hoffnung
auf mehr internationale Hilfe
jetzt blicken wir erstmal nach
Deutschland Hans übrigens mit den
Warnstreiks in Luftverkehr ja die
Gewerkschaft Verdi hatte für heute
Flughafen beschäftigte zum gemeinsamen
Warnstreik von bodenverkehrs
Bediensteten Luftsicherheit und
öffentlichen Dienst aufgerufen betroffen
waren unter anderem die Drehkreuze
Frankfurt und München mehr als 2000
Flüge für ihn aus im Tarifstreit im
öffentlichen Dienst fordert Verdi für
die Beschäftigten 10,5% mehr Geld
mindestens aber 500 Euro im Monat mehr
nach der Wiederholungswahl zum Berliner
Abgeordnetenhaus haben sich Vertreter
der CDU zu ersten Sondierungen mit SPD
und Grünen getroffen
CDU-Spitzenkandidat Wegener sprach
danach mit Blick auf beide Parteien von
Überschneidungen nächste Woche sollen
weitere Sondierungen Folgen Ziel der CDU
ist eine Koalition mit SPD oder grünen
um ins Rote Rathaus einziehen zu können
in den Erdbebengebieten in der Türkei
und Syrien steigt die Gefahr von Seuchen
und anderen Krankheiten weiter an in
besonders schwer betroffenen Orten wie
etwa in am Tag hier verunreinigen Müll
und Fäkalien das Grundwasser immer mehr
dort geht mittlerweile das
trinkwasserhaus ärzte warnen zudem vor
einer drohenden medikamentenknappheit
inzwischen ist die Zahl der Todesopfer
auf insgesamt fast
44.000 gestiegen
wenn sie spenden wollen dass
Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe hat
folgendes konto.de
65-100
400-100 400 Stichwort ZDF Erdbeben
Türkei Syrien informationen auch unter
spenden.zdf.de oder im zdf-
in Trier sind bei einem Polizeieinsatz
für eine Diskothek in der Nacht fünf
Beamte verletzt worden Hintergrund war
eine Auseinandersetzung in dem Lokal zu
der die Polizei gerufen worden war und
40 Menschen gingen daraufhin vor der
Diskothek auf die Beamten los unter
anderem mit Glasflaschen und Holzstücken
ein Polizist gab daraufhin zwei
Warnschüsse ab zwei Verdächtige wurden
in Gewahrsam genommen die Polizei sucht
nach weiteren Angreifern und zeugen
Iran gab es heute wieder Proteste in den
Großstädten Teheran und Maschad und in
iranischen Kurdengebieten gingen wieder
viele Menschen auf die Straße sie trauen
sich das nach wie vor trotz der
Polizeigewalt trotz der Hinrichtungen
junge Frauen und Männer die vom Regime
getötet werden weil sie es gewagt haben
zu kritisieren Freiheiten zu fördern
oder sich gegen Unrecht zu verwehren wie
die Studentinnen
von ihrem Schicksal handelt der Film
sieben Winter in Teheran der jetzt auf
der Berlinale vorgestellt wird Phase
erzählt die Geschichte dahinter
jeden Abend zündet Schule Park ravan
Kerzen an für ihre Tochter rehane
reyhane starb durch den Strang
hingerichtet im Oktober 2014 in einem
iranischen Gefängnis Event in last
selbst in den letzten Stunden vor ihrer
Hinrichtung hatte ich die Hoffnung dass
vielleicht doch noch ein Wunder
geschieht
sieben Jahre lang kämpft die Mutter um
eine Begnadigung ihrer Tochter von
diesem Kampf erzählt der Film sieben
Winter in Teheran
2007 wird die 19-Jährige zum Tode
verurteilt weil sie einen Mann der sie
vergewaltigen wollte erstochen hatte der
Mann war Mitarbeiter des iranischen
Geheimdienstes die Mutter versucht das
Gericht und die Familie des Opfers von
der Unschuld ihrer Tochter zu überzeugen
vergebens
für ihren Film wertete Regisseurin
Steffi niederzoll zahllose Dokumente aus
wie Tagebuchaufzeichnungen Telefon
Mitschnitte und Verhörprotokolle das was
riane beschreibt ist
pure Gewalt was ihr da widerfahren ist
und es ist ein ganz Mini kleiner Teil in
diesem Film drin weil ich das Gefühl
hatte dass der Film ist sowieso relativ
schwer ertragbar und irgendwo muss ich
zu der Grenze haben was man
Zuschauer in zumuten kann schwer zu
ertragen ist auch die Gewalt mit der die
aktuellen Proteste in ihrer
niedergeschlagen werden seit vergangenen
September kommt es immer wieder zu
Krawallen zu Toten und Verletzten vier
junge Männer wurden im Zusammenhang mit
den Protesten bereits hingerichtet
[Applaus]
bei jeder Todesstrafe die verhängt wird
und bei jedem falschen Geständnis oder
erzwungen Geständnis genau denke ich
natürlich an die Geschichte von Rihanna
und ihrer Familie und merkt so wie sich
alles dann doch wiederholt
der Film wird bei der Berlinale sicher
für Aufsehen sorgen Aufsehen das schöne
paar krabbern nutzen will denn auch nach
dem Tod ihrer Tochter kämpft sie weiter
gegen ein System das nicht straft
sondern Rache übt
wenn wir es schaffen dass sich eine
Schlinge löst und wir ein Leben retten
können dann ist das ein großer Erfolg
wir müssen weitermachen und versuchen
dass die Hinrichtungen in Iran gestoppt
werden
sie hat Holzfiguren geschnitzt von
Müttern die ihre Kinder durch Kugeln
oder den Galgen verloren haben so wie
sie selbst und dieses System sagt Schule
pakravan produziert immer noch Mütter
wie mich wieder und wieder bis heute
und jetzt noch mal Heinz mit dem Blick
nach Deutschland auf die deutsche
Wirtschaft da schauen wir ein weiteres
Mal in dieser Woche auf die Autobranche
von Mercedes-Benz gab es heute einen
aus- und Rückblick zu den
Geschäftszahlen weil realer wie also
laufen die Geschäfte sehr gut soweit
mercedes hat wie andere Autobauer auch
ja unter dem chipmangel gelitten und die
Halbleiter die zur Verfügung standen vor
allem in seine teuren luxus-karossen
verbaut in die werfen beim Verkauf
einfach deutlich mehr aber als die
kleineren Modelle ja und außerdem konnte
Mercedes beim Kunden höhere Preise
durchsetzen und all das spülte dem
Autobauer viel Geld in die Kassen
2022 unterm Strich ein Gewinn von fast
15 Milliarden Euro ein Drittel mehr als
im Jahr zuvor glänzende zahlen aber
verantwortlich für die gute Bilanz waren
vor allem die Verbrenner e-Autos sind
gegen verkaufen sich nur schleppend
magere sechs Prozent im Verhältnis zum
Gesamtabsatz da hat Mercedes für die
hilft also noch einiges aufzuholen denn
die satten Gewinne mit den Verbrennern
sind endlich und heute Abend sogar um 22
Uhr wurde bekannt gegeben wer in den DAX
aufsteigt genau das ist die Commerzbank
sie rückt in den DAX auf da dürften
jetzt die Sektkorken knallen für sie ist
es ja ein Comeback 2018 musste sie den
Platz räumen ausgerechnet für Wirecard
das spätere skandalunternehmen jetzt
erfüllt sie wieder die
Aufnahmebedingungen eine davon zwei
Jahre in Folge profitabel zu sein ja und
die Commerzbank die ersetzt Linde der
Industriegase Hersteller geht freiwillig
für den DAX ist das schon ein Dämpfer
Linde war von Anfang an dabei und auch
noch wertvollstes DAX Mitglied ihm kehrt
sie nun den Rücken künftig will sie nur
noch an der Wall Street notiert sein
vielen Dank
Tony Marshall ist gestorben gestern
Abend im Alter von 85 Jahren der
musikalische Durchbruch gelang dem
Opernsänger mit dem Schlager schöne Maid
[Musik]
die schöne Maid ist es die Tony Marshall
1971 berühmt und in der Nacht zu einem
der erfolgreichsten Schlagersänger in
Deutschland macht Tony Marshall erobert
die Hitparaden verkauft mehr als 30
Millionen Platten
und weiter jetzt mit dem ersten Platz
sie hören bereits im Hintergrund und
wissen worum es geht es geht um Sony
Marshall und komm gib mir deine Hand
dort ist da Dieter Thomas Heck ist es
dann auch der Tony Marshall zum
fröhlichmacher der Nation erklärt
[Musik]
1938 kommt der als Herbert Anton blöd
zur Welt als Tony Marshall wird der
studierte Opernsänger ein Star in den
80er Jahren dann mit eigener
Fernsehsendung im ZDF
[Musik]
vor eineinhalb Jahren dann sein letztes
Album gemeinsam mit seinen Söhnen Mark
und Pascal das Wichtigste für ihn also
vereint die Familie und die Musik
zum Sport im Skeleton haben Tina
Herrmann und Christopher Grotheer
jeweils den Gesamtweltcup gewonnen beim
Saisonfinale heute in secula Lettland
vor Hermann auf Platz 1 gother wurde
dritter und Katharina Althaus hat das
Weltcup-Springen im rumänischen was noch
gewonnen die 26-Jährige Oberstdorferin
setzte sich auf der Normalschanze mit
Sprüngen auf
89,5 und 98 einhalb Meter gegen die
Österreicherin Eva pinkelnick durch so
wie gegen iron Maria sandal aus Norwegen
Althaus die in diesem Winter bereits
ihren sechsten Einzelsieg feierte geht
als Favoritin in die kommende Woche
beginnende nordische Ski WM
schon im Gespräch mit Boris Pistorius
erwähnt alle Umfrageergebnisse
präsentiert ihn jetzt Matthias
guten Abend willkommen zum
Politbarometer knapp eine Woche ist es
her da hat Berlin noch einmal gewählt
und der Rot-Grün roten Landesregierung
an Denkzettel verpasst die CDU fährt
dagegen einen deutlichen Wahlsieg ein es
ist ein klares Zeichen der Wähler kein
weiter so wie bisher
das Ergebnis wirkt sich auch auf die
politische Stimmung im Bund aus wenn am
nächsten Sonntag Bundestagswahl wäre
käme die SPD auf 20 Prozent minus 1
cdu/csu legen deutlich zu und würden
stärkste Kraft 30 Prozent plus 3 die
Grünen unverändert 19 die FDP weit
dahinter 5 die AFD 14 die Linke 5% alle
drei minus 1
die Ampel aus SPD Grünen und FDP hätte
damit keine Mehrheit die Zufriedenheit
mit der Regierung aber bleibt wie in den
letzten Monaten wenn auch auf niedrigem
Niveau
die Bundesregierung macht ihre Arbeit
eher gut das Finden
53%. 41 Prozent attestieren ihr
schlechter Arbeit wäre die Union an der
Regierung würde sie es besser machen
sagen 22 Prozent 21 Prozent gehen davon
aus CDU CSU würden einen schlechteren
Job machen die meisten aber 53 Prozent
erwarten kann Unterschied
dass das Berliner Wahlergebnis den
Zusammenhalt innerhalb der Ampel
verschlechtern könnte das glaubt gut ein
Drittel der Befragten die meisten
erwarten dass ich da nichts ändert
schauen wir auf unsere Top Ten also die
Bewertung der zehn wichtigsten
Politikerinnen und Politiker nach
Sympathie und Leistung
auf das Skala von plus 5 bis -5 ist
Alice Weidel weiter klares Schlusslicht
minus 2,9 verschlechtert davor Sahra
Wagenknecht minus 0,8 unverändert
Christian Lindner rutscht wieder ab -0,3
Friedrich Merz weiter bei -0,2
Markus Söder und Karl Lauterbach beide
mit zu gewinnen bei 0,1
Anna Lena baerbock verliert etwas 0,6
Olaf Scholz dagegen etwas besser 0,7
Robert Habeck weiter 0,9 Boris Pistorius
ist zum ersten Mal dabei und setzt sich
gleich an die Spitze 1,6
für den Verteidigungsminister also ein
Senkrechtstart in unsere Top Ten der
Krieg in der Ukraine bleibt fester
Bestandteil der politischen Tagesordnung
wie etwa beim migrationsgipfel diese
Woche viele Menschen suchen weiter Asyl
in Deutschland vor allem auch aus der
Ukraine
mehr als die Hälfte der Befragten meint
dass Deutschland die vielen Flüchtlinge
verkraften kann das sehen vor allem die
Anhänger der Grünen so mehrheitliche
Zustimmung auch bei den Anhängern von
Linke und SPD die Anhänger von Union und
FDP sind da gespalten
wie die Flüchtlinge unterkommen liegt
vor allem bei den Ländern und Kommunen
und die sehen sich zunehmend überfordert
in unserer Umfrage meinen zwei Drittel
dass der Bund die Kommunen bei der
Unterbringung der Flüchtlinge nicht
genug unterstützt
der Krieg in der Ukraine wird sich in
der kommenden Woche zum ersten Mal
jähren ein Ende ist nicht in Sicht
gerade mal 19 Prozent gehen davon aus
dass Russland und die Ukraine in den
nächsten Monaten über einen Kriegsende
verhandeln werden die allermeisten 78%
sind skeptisch erwarten das nicht
der ukrainische Präsident selenski
umwirbt der weil den Westen unter
anderem mit Besuchen bei den
Unterstützern in Europa es geht um
Waffen und nicht zuletzt auch um einen
EU-Beitritt
eine Mehrheit von 60 Prozent spricht
sich für einen EU-Beitritt der Ukraine
in den nächsten Jahren aus 34% wollen
das nicht
die Weltordnung ist in Bewegung nicht
zuletzt mit dem Aufstieg Chinas
eine Mehrheit der Deutschen fürchtet
dass die Volksrepublik eine Bedrohung
für westliche Demokratien sein könnte
wer wird künftig die bestimmende macht
in der Welt sein haben wir gefragt
China Glauben 47 Prozent
33% erwarten dass die USA bestimmend
sein werden gerade mal acht Prozent
haben Europa auf dem Zettel Russland nur
ein Prozent
im Kreml wird man das wohl anders sehen
der bisherige Verlauf des
Angriffskrieges auf die Ukraine
jedenfalls zeigt vor allem eines
Selbstüberschätzung
das war unser Bericht über die Stimmung
im Land die Grafiken und alle
Informationen zu unseren Umfragen finden
Sie wie immer im ZDF Text ab Seite 165
in unserer ZDF heute App und auf ZDF
heute.de wie die repräsentativen
Umfragen der Forschungsgruppe Wein
zustande kommen Informationen zur
Methodik und zu den Qualitätsstandards
finden Sie unter politbarometer.zdf.de
vielen Dank für Ihr Interesse das
nächste reguläre Politbarometer gibt es
dann am 3 März hier folgt jetzt das
Wetter und dann die heute-show einen
schönen Abend auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter derzeit ist es ja
recht ungemütlich über Deutschland denn
Sturmtiefs überqueren und während dieses
Sturmtief hier ostwärts zieht von
Skandinavien aus Weg kommt dieses Tief
hier und überquert uns einmal
südostwärts hat natürlich viel Wind
dabei und auch Regen so in der kommenden
Nacht im Nordwesten verlagert sich nach
Osten und Südosten ganz im Süden an den
Alpen ist es trocken und auch ganz im
Norden Richtung Ostsee da haben wir es
mit der orkanartigen Böden über Nacht zu
tun Temperaturen sinken dort auf vier
Grad sonst ist es deutlich mehr davon
nach Westen hin mit 11 Graz Richtung
Niederrhein und morgen dann im Westen
kräftiger Regen der sich dann ostwärts
verlagert sonst aber in der Mitte das
ist relativ wenig das wird gerade so
reichen um die Straßen nass zu machen
ansonsten im Süden scheint doch dann die
Sonne häufiger aber das ganze mit
kräftigen Wind aus West Sturmböen 50 bis
80 km eine Stunde sind drin in den
höheren Lagen zum Beispiel den östlichen
Mittelgebirgen können durchaus
orkanartige Böden dabei sein und auch in
den Frühstunden Richtung Ostsee das
lässt dann aber nach und dann sind dann
höchstens nur noch Sturmböen dabei und
die Temperaturen dazu 5 Grad Richtung
Schleswig-Holstein und 15 Grad im
Südwesten Deutschlands das ist schon
sehr mild für die Jahreszeit und für die
nächsten Tage bleiben größtenteils mit
Regen der allmählich südwärts zieht am
Sonntag 5 bis 13 Grad Montag bis 16 und
im Norden Sturm und damit ein schöner
Abend